[Applause]
[Music]
this is two more Hussein standing in for
freelance reviewer Richard waiting for
his review of Need for Speed payback
Need for Speed payback is the kind of
arcade racer that never requires you to
lift your foot off the accelerator
it's brazen drifting is effortlessly
achieved with aggressive cornering and
feathering the brakes and judicious
bursts of nitrous are your best friend
down any stretch of open road but
paybacks arcade sensibilities aren't
enough to save the game surrounding it
from wallowing in mundanity
payback takes its cues from the Dwayne
Johnson centric fast and furious movies
with heists and over-the-top action as
the order of the day features a
derivative tale of betrayal and
vengeance set against the backdrop of an
expansive open world that surprises with
its range and variety the fowl Las Vegas
of silver rock is a glistening urban
jungle of glitz and greed that gradually
broadens out into sunkissed deserts
precarious mountain ranges and the
twisting turns that skirt through its
forest wilderness fortune valleys slice
of diverse country side is picturesque
at times but it's locales are never
distinct or memorable enough to make a
lasting impression and speaks to an open
world that fulfills its role without
ever standing out
and the same can be said of payback
story after a three plucky protagonists
are double-crossed during a heist gone
awry at the game's outset they set a
plan in motion to exact revenge on their
conniving defector and the ominous
criminal syndicate she represents it's a
simple enough conceit that gives purpose
to the game structure as you're tasked
with defeating various archetypal Racing
crews in order to earn a shot at your
nemesis but there's also a kind of force
planner that's become commonplace in
video games and is dutifully featured
here all of this might have been
bearable but the narrative is so
prevalent in everything you do that
there's little respite from the
hackneyed storytelling in frequent story
missions do at least latch on to the
pomp and spectacle of paybacks fast and
furious inspiration but it falters here
too all these moments of vehicle-based
history on its feature its most visually
arresting set pieces they're frequently
spoiled when the game rips control away
from you just as things are getting
interesting in favor of a canned
cutscene this might look more cinematic
but being forced to watch the scene you
could feasibly control from behind the
wheel is incredibly disheartening and
feeds into paybacks inherent dullness
[Music]
my previous Need for Speed games you'll
pull up the checkpoints within the open
world with race off-road drift drag and
run events providing plenty of variety
race an off-road event speak for
themselves and drift competitions offer
an anomalous thrill getting your car
sideways is so easy that there's a
singular pleasure in simply seeing how
long you can maintain a drift for while
drag events are short and sweet but soon
grow repetitive as you're essentially
just staring at a meter to time your
gear shifts meanwhile simple runner
events focus on police chases and time
dashes between various points on the map
the problem is outside of drift events
where it's a non-factor the sense of
speed in payback is startlingly lacking
the speedometer may say so but there's
no tangible sense that you're hurtling
down the road at 160 miles per hour in a
few guzzling death-trap
motion blur attempts to sell a fast pace
but never quite captures a sensation
that the wards rushing by it's all
surprisingly pedestrian with passive AI
and police chases that are elementary
the cops might be aggressive but you
never have to out think or outmaneuver
them escaping is as simple as reaching a
specific checkpoint this all combines to
make a game that's bland and
unfulfilling and is only exacerbated by
the sheer amount of grinding you're
required to do each vehicle you own has
six slots for speed cards that represent
various pods under the hood and come
with perks that will increase particular
stats and your cars overall level each
event has a recommended level and since
there's no scaling this means you'll
usually have to spend upwards of 40
minutes or so collecting speed cards to
upgrade your car you're essentially
reaching these frustrating choke points
where the only way to progress through
the story is by going back and replaying
old events in order to earn enough speed
cards to bump up your level and when you
factor in the ability to expedite the
process with microtransaction loot boxes
it feels geared towards encouraging you
to part with real money unless you want
to spend time replaying lukewarm parts
of the game over again
can it you know most it's not everyday
got to take where's dB 11 first school
need for speed payback spinel racing is
only magnified by this focus on grinding
the simple almost retro handling model
provides occasional bouts of fun but
it's never enough to escape paybacks
flaws with an unwillingness to let you
partake in its most hair-raising moments
and a general drabness that seeps into
every layer of the game fast and furious
this is not and that's a disappointing
outcome
[Music]
you